Hello Freak bitches,
everybody so freaked,
doubt and,
and hair was more of like an eyelash for
the vagina for periods and stuff so it
wouldn't get everywhere.
And that's why girls are,
that's not what it is.
The uh,
the butthole hair was always disturbing
though.
Yeah.
I don't like nobody ever liked the
buddle air cause some girls just did not
know what they're doing when it came to
wiping.
And back then nobody had a big day and
nobody had baby wipes.
It was toilet paper.
Sometimes some of it stuck around
joints for a little gi joe figures
super tightly rolled up.
Did you know those little shit joint
could,
you know there's little notes trimmers
that you buy.
You use that for your asshole also.
You can't,
yeah,
I was unaware of the,
yeah.
Well it's not rocket science.
It's not like trying to figure out solar
power,
nose hair trimmers on your eyes.
It's just,
if it cuts hair cuts,
hair,
you know,
it just does.
And it doesn't like cut you and stuff.
Well,
couldn't you get like one of those face
shavers?
A little nice ones down there with your
ass?
You know my shaving your ass all hair.
Oh I just leave my watering and girls.
You know what though?
You could do a way better job of
cleaning it if your asshole is shaved,
but your asshole will grow that hair
back like a wild Bush and then in a
couple of days you'll be just squeezing
your ass cheeks everywhere he go to keep
from just digging in.
They're clawing at your asshole like a
wolf trying to bury at Caribou.
Flicking that stubble.
I get enough double and ball stubble.
All symbols are how come my face double
barely bothers me.
My head stubble does like I got a lot of
double up here right now.
No,
doesn't bother me at all.
But Jesus Christ my hall,
I just
moving around in your chair just good
when you wipe your ass and he'd grab
like a bundle of hair on the way out.
You know what's the best man?
One wipe charlies.
You ever try the,
I want them so bad.
It's like a big dude wipe like that kind
of a thing where he use a baby wipe.
They made.
They made from men,
but they don't smell like flowers.
Like you just got ass fucked by a flower
forest anymore.
Yeah.
Well I that Japanese thing is the shit
man.
Yeah.
Isn't gonna install one in here?
Yeah,
I'm going to install it in here
eventually.
Does it shoot like high pressure water?
Loving the shit.
Hang out for an hour.
It's a high pressure water pressure.
Water,
warm air.
It dries your ass hole off.
There's two different speeds to the
water.
It's shoots in your asshole totos Ooh.
It also cleans your vagina.
If you're a Gal,
he cleans your vagina area.
You can back your badge up,
get a little tingly,
tingly and if you know he has a little
time and the alcohol.
What do you went to join the Gal we went
to Japan.
I just sat there for seriously for a
half hour with the,
the one shooting and my asshole because
it just felt so because it hit like the
back wall of your app,
but hold that long.
I'd have to do it to feel like I was
like getting cla.
I still feel that have to do paper
afterwards.
No,
no,
you don't even walk.
I was worried it was so clean.
I mean it was like taking a shower for
your butthole.
Pretty meticulous.
You can not doing as good a job.
I'm telling you,
you just smearing.
Even if you use baby wipes,
you just smearing the show over your
hair.
Okay.
Imagine if I took some shit and it just
rubbed into the top of your head.
You're like,
I'm good.
I got a baby.
Wipe the fuck
you ain't never accept that.
But if I had to get in the shower and
you would clean your asshole there,
fair enough.
But,
but if you told me,
you told me I have 70 baby wipes in a
row,
toilet paper,
I'd take a show there and get in the
shower.
Jesus Christ.
Oh No,
that was a choice.
Quit this fork and shit all day too.
Don't worry about it.
I rubbed it with 70 baby wipes.
I be like,
ah,
that's not enough.
You've got to watch this fucking thing.
You got to get it in the washing
machine.
It needs hot water.
It's sons.
But again,
let's say baby wipes and Willie Vapor,
just try to get my method approved.
It's still shut your pick shower before
the shower
and fairness.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't do anything.
I don't go out for the day though until
I shower after I should stand up or to
wipe or a sit down.
Stand up as sitting down.
Even a possibility.
Fuck wipes are asked sitting down.
You must have really shitty cups.
What are your cuffs?
I don't do it.
He does.
I wanted you to do.
It's like I stayed in that find a
target.
Hit Up.
Jamie,
do you stand up or sit down?
No,
there's people,
most people sit and like their sleeves
smelled or watch guaranteed
shit.
One of my buddies told me he goes from
the front here,
like reach up between his legs and
plausible smell his balls.
Oh yeah.
How'd you Jesus Christ.
You don't,
he's an ass.
Damn.
Do you pay attention to all of the
scientific research that's being done in
genetic engineering and changing?
Is there anything that's on,
yeah,
like um,
they actually identified the Dwarf Jean,
like they've been able to identify the
gene that causes dwarfism and this
debate has gone on as their,
as the technology keeps getting closer
to the point where we could actually do
this.
But there's some debate going is if we
can remove that gene,
if we can prevent your child from having
dwarfism,
should we,
and a lot of dwarves were like,
no,
we shouldn't do it.
It's playing God.
It's stumped.
And I'm,
I'm there going,
yeah,
you should absolutely remove it.
Absolutely.
Why would you want your kid to go
through?
I mean,
granted,
I've been lucky at like,
like I said,
I've only had one surgery and I made a
good career with the hand that I was
dealt.
But there's a lot of little people I
know that,
that haven't,
that don't that and then get constantly
made fun of their entire lives are
hidden away by their parents.
Why would you want your kid to go
through that and as a dwarf,
you know,
what struggles that you had growing up?
Why would you,
why would you intentionally put those
pains on your child?
I don't understand that.
I don't,
it's hard to understand a lot of
decisions that people make.
Yeah.
A lot of rationalizations that people
may,
yeah.
Like,
um,
like one reason that I'm able to be a
comedian and sort of have this sense of
humor about it is because my dad was
amazing,
is amazing.
Uh,
like when I was born,
he found out that I was going to be a
dwarf.
So he would go to these,
uh,
LPA,
little people of America meetings and he
would find out about it and he was like,
Oh shit,
my kid's going to get made fun of a lot.
Like his life is going to be weird.
So his philosophy was when I was growing
up,
he would make fun of me first,
but he would do it in like,
in like a supportive way.
Like he would fuck with me,
but then say,
okay,
I just insulted you,
hit me back with something,
hit me back and then get,
cause th this is going to happen to you
later.
Bye.
It's like training you.
Yeah.
So by the time I got to kindergarten I
like,
I remember kindergarten walking in in a
a kid just laughing at me going,
ha ha,
you're little.
And I looked at him and went,
ha ha,
your mom doesn't live with your dad
anymore and kindergarten,
kindergarten and fucking like I got sent
to the principal's office for like,
like hurting this kid's feelings.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
And like,
and they call my dad,
we're like,
we're going to call your father.
I'm like,
fucking do it.
You turned you to be a co comedian.
Kind of did.
Because now like when I get a heckler,
it's like,
do you think you're going to say
anything to me that I haven't heard on
the street that I haven't heard walking
down and some kid having would be like
saying a comment like I've had,
I've had parents bring their children up
to me when the line is too long at the
mall Santa and go,
hey,
tell this guy what,
what you want or you've had that happen
to mayor.
I want to talk to you about some shit,
dude.
Let's stop.
Because I was working out in my gym
yesterday dying.
Okay.
All I'm doing is hitting pads.
No one's hitting me back.
I'm fucking exhausted.
And when I like to do,
when I'm,
when I'm working on is I like to put
fights on for motivation and I'm
watching you and uh,
you're,
you're fighting in the,
the last man standing tournament.
You got to fight three times this,
this night.
You're,
you're fighting you,
you're going for fucking rounds.
Exhausting.
Ridiculous fight.
And then I remember this shit.
Oh Shit.
Oops.
We just dropped elvis.
Elvis has left the building.
Yeah,
I remember this shit,
right.
Brian Logan sent me this picture.
What the fuck,
dude?
How are you able to have that kind of
cardio?
I mean,
you fought three times that night for
four rounds.
The first fight before you,
uh,
you,
won by knockout and you're,
you're smoking cigarettes.
Yeah.
How's that possible?
Oh,
Joe,
I didn't want to talk about this last
time.
When was this?
When was the cigarette?
That cigarette was right after the fight
with,
uh,
Robert Thomas in the dressing room.
Ryan lochte Loco.
Shut up my dress from him before I got
in the shower and it was like taking
pictures and I'm like,
he's like,
can I,
can I take,
I won't take a photo.
I'm like,
Ryan,
just take the picture.
Here it is.
Now,
when you fought in the tournament,
you didn't have any cigarettes in
between fights or anything?
Did you have to assignment?
I went outside and how necessary true
story.
Oh my God.
You had a cigarette and then fought
twice more.
Yeah.
It's coming to an end up getting really
sick of smoking and I'm getting really
sick of explaining,
having this conversation.
Joe Joe's the reason when I quit,
this will be the reason.
Okay.